the first shot of the movie shows us a
delivery truck with illinois license
place but this movie doesn't take place
in illinois this is actually a little
sign for fans that curse of chucky would
take the franchise back to its roots
that this entry would return to horror
by focusing on suspense and
psychological manipulation and more in
line with the first movie child's play
which took place in chicago illinois
appropriately this movie would honor the
original in many ways from new
characters filling the shoes of classic
characters bringing back iconic kills
and even secrets hidden on computer
screens and in the background of an old
friend's apartment to learn about all of
the ways that this movie brought back
elements of child's play and many other
details you might have missed stick
around to the end of this video this
video is sponsored by amazon music
[Music]
i've been excited to do this episode
ever since i started covering the chucky
franchise two years ago because this is
by far the best chucky movie no i'm not
supposed to say my opinion but come on
it's not even close if you didn't
already know you may be surprised to
learn that curse was directed by the
same director who did c these movies
could not be more different scene was a
raunchy colorful over-the-top dark
comedy while curse is a dark subdued
tragic suspense film but you may be less
surprised by this quick sobering up that
takes place between these two if you
know who that director is it's don
mancini the original writer and creator
of child's play as i mentioned the tone
of this movie goes back towards that
1988 original but what i didn't mention
is it goes past that and keeps going
into its own territory and in my opinion
this is how you play to chucky's strings
of course this is not a review you're
here for things you missed so why don't
we get back into them
[Music]
for the first time in the franchise we
don't start with chucky coming back to
life but rather by meeting our other
characters starting with a paraplegic
woman named nika pierce and her mom
sarah pierce we see that sarah has some
health issues because her bedside table
is filled with anxiety medications and
antidepressants this is an important
detail that comes back later and helps
cast doubt on the idea that chucky is
really alive in the original child's
play we as the audience know that
chucky's alive but the adults in the
story don't believe that he is curse
puts its own twist on this by making the
audience doubt that chucky's alive
obviously if you've seen a chucky movie
before you go into this one thinking
that he is alive just like all the
others but when we don't see proof of
that until much later you start to
wonder if one of the human characters is
simply using a good guy doll to cover up
his or her own criminal actions i just
wish they would have left out this
opening credit that says brad dorf as
the voice of chucky i get why they have
to put that in there contractually but
it would have been better if the movie
made us doubt that this doll was the
real chucky and then hit us with that
surprise actually it is chucky you could
get rid of a couple other shots too to
really go all in on the mystery aspect
but one thing you may have noticed was
the elevator inside of nika's house it's
the same kind of old-fashioned elevator
seen in the barkley's apartment in the
first movie we also see a chucky pov
which i don't think we've seen since
child's play one we see charles lee
ray's human form that we haven't seen
since the first one and near the end of
the movie nika stabs the chucky doll
with a knife and the fluff from inside
the doll shoots up in the air and then
slowly floats down on her it almost
looks like snow the first movie takes
place entirely in the snow but curse
isn't just here for superficial visual
callbacks to 1988. if you think about
the character dynamics there are even
more similarities for one chucky finally
has a new best friend till the end that
is a young kid that he psychologically
manipulates instead of andy this time
it's little girl alex he keeps his true
nature a secret by only communicating
with her and through her because she's
too young to understand that dolls
shouldn't be sentient
oh chubby wants to know what's for
dinner
chucky wants to watch the nine o'clock
news and he doesn't hold back any
graphic language he said that life's up
and then you die bleeding like a stuck
pig
he said that maggie was a real [ __ ] and
got what she deserved in addition to the
child's doll relationship the child in
each movie has another adult who's close
to them in cursive chucky alice has a
special bond with her aunt nika and in
child's play andy has his aunt maggie
who isn't really his aunt but she's just
such a close family friend that he calls
her as such in reality she's more of a
nanny and curse also has a dedicated
nanny so that role is kind of split into
two characters but another similarity is
what happens to each respective ant
character in child's play chuckie pushes
aunt maggie through the window of the
high rise apartment and in curse he
rolls ant nika's wheelchair through a
railing sending her off the second floor
landing in the foyer if you're an
observant chucky fan you may have
noticed the first big confirmation that
chucky is actually alive when alice
finds him in the bathroom he's got a
bloodshot eyes it's actually in the
previous movie seed of chucky that we
see what happens to the doll's eyes when
the awakening ritual is performed on
them so this means that alice's new doll
is in fact possessed like the dolls that
we've seen throughout the franchise when
chuckie starts taking victims at the
house nika's brother-in-law ian starts
to point the finger at her the situation
is somewhat similar to the plot of the
1982 film the thing featuring richard
master it makes me wonder if the name of
nika's physician dr master is an
intentional reference dr mazur said i
was fine dr mazur said that extreme
stress any kind of even mild shock they
pronounce it a little bit funny in the
movie but if you look at the script and
subtitles it's spelled the same way that
richard master spells his name it might
not be an intentional reference but it's
an uncommon enough name to make me
entertain the possibility after the very
tense dinner scene nika brings the doll
upstairs in the elevator when the power
goes out and when the lights come back
on she sees this
the doll's head had spun around 180
degrees leading to this very unsettling
moment with alice
hey wanna play this is a move we saw
chucky make to scare damian in the
beginning of bride which at the time i
mentioned as being a reference to the
exorcist but i guess now he's just
absorbed that into his own repertoire we
see it again later in the film nika
would soon discover the truth about
charles lee ray on the internet and the
articles contain some previously unknown
information
[Music]
charles lee ray's crimes would
eventually be covered on the podcast
hack and slash nearly a decade later if
a character in the world of chucky
wanted to listen to this podcast a good
option for them would be amazon music
amazon music has more than 10 million
free podcast episodes to listen to
including mine if i had one which as of
right now i don't but you can listen to
the breathtaking true crime podcast dr
death miracle man which is on amazon
music two weeks before other platforms
personally i think i'll be listening to
the let's read podcast for some scary
stories from my friend who claimed that
he has no arms after i challenged him to
a push-up contest but amazon music isn't
just for listening to podcasts they also
have music
believe it or not there's this feature
that gives you fun facts about the band
that you've been listening to so i've
been testing my weezer trivia i know
more than you for a limited time new
customers can try amazon music unlimited
free for three months no credit card
required go to amazon.comworld
wait what amazon.com
easy's world that exists
oh wow this is for real link in
description it renews automatically
cancel any time terms apply bye
or stay here actually we're going back
to the video
you may be wondering why this movie is
called cursive chalky it could be that
this doll is cursed by the soul of
charles lee ray using voodoo but that
happens all the way back in the first
just movie your [ __ ] mouth shut
chucky stop cursing oh so that's why
it's called cursive chucky this is also
a callback to a lion from tyler in
child's play 3 who is similarly not a
fan of chucky's foul
mouth charles stop swearing after alice
recounts the obscene things that chucky
said to her mom she also mentions this
curious detail he says there is no god
and we hear chucky himself say this
later in the movie
there is no god kind of a strange thing
to say for someone who literally is only
alive because an ancient voodoo god lent
him some of his power has chucky
forgotten about that or what i guess
maybe what he meant to say was your god
doesn't exist the voodoo stuff is a
smaller part of the story than ever
before but when we flash back to 88 the
room that charles holds sarah pierce
captive in is decorated with voodoo
artifacts and the knife that he uses to
maim her pregnant belly has a white
snake on it if you've seen my horror
history episode on dumbella the haitian
deity that charles calls upon to
transfer souls you know that in the
voodoo religion dembele is believed to
be a white snake being which we see
briefly painted on charles wall in
child's play one if you don't watch
horror history you're a [ __ ] loser go
back to rolling around in a bathtub full
of cheetos and eating them early on
curse of chucky focuses on building its
own characters and atmosphere rather
than continuing the story from the
previous movies when nikki contacts the
delivery company to find out where the
doll was sent from she hears the words
evidence depository meaning that
something happened between the end of
seed where chucky was in pieces around
la and the beginning of curse where he's
put together in mail i think we're
supposed to assume that the police
eventually collected the pieces and
tiffany acquired them and reassembled
him just like she did in the opening of
bride where we see chucky's remains
locked up in an evidence room the movie
doesn't really acknowledge the older
films at all until nika researches the
doll's past the search results rank from
the most recent events to the oldest
starting with the unsolved los angeles
homicide website that details the events
of seed then the niagara falls and
hackensack homicide links in both
locations that chucky and tiffany
terrorized in bride then there's the
kent military academy homicide
investigation from the aftermath of
child's play 3 the chicago double
homicide case which involves kevin and
joanne simpson from child's play 2 and
then finally the chicago triple homicide
aka aunt maggie eddie caputo and dr
ardmore in child's play 1. nika then
looks at the newspaper archives which
mentioned that charles lee ray was the
chief suspect of a local kidnapping this
is an early reveal of what we learned
later in the movie sarah pierce is the
woman who was kidnapped of course this
text isn't on screen long enough to read
it but i love when there are little
clues like that that you can go back to
her research is interrupted when the
electricity in the house goes haywire
because upstairs chucky kicked over a
bucket of water to electrocute the nanny
jill this is seriously the worst outlet
placement ever was this house designed
by ea
women
can't live with them
period
that might be a reference to bride of
chucky where chuck and his woman
literally just bicker for the entire
movie also you have to wonder what was
going through barbs had it during this
scene
i don't know what tiffany was
complaining about in bride okay it's a
knife but this scene showcases one of
the cool things about this movie which
is that chucky has gotten better at
being a killer doll gone are the days of
him trying to overpower people who are
four times bigger than him now it's all
about surprise and psychological
manipulation which is honestly way
scarier and the choice to have nika in a
wheelchair is brilliant because when
there finally is a physical
confrontation her handicap really levels
the playing field in my previous
episodes i talked about how the bride
and seed arc was influenced by the
scream franchise but between the focus
on suspense rather than violence the
twist ending and the use of a disabled
character who finds a way to use her
disability to her advantage i'm guessing
that curse might have been more inspired
by the works of m night shyamalan
seriously nika using her own legs as an
axe board is the biggest alpha move i've
ever seen i don't know why ian doesn't
try to stop the axe whatsoever but
whatever nika's the last one now she
uses that ax to cut chucky's head off
something that happens to him in both
child's play 1 and seat of chucky but
this time is notably different because
his head just pops off like you'd expect
a doll head too there's no blood or guts
which means he probably hasn't been
resurrected for very long and hasn't
started to turn human yet as he does in
the other movies although the
consistency with this rule is about as
consistent as my instagram posting
schedule as usual chucky getting
dismembered does not slow him down and
he launches into a flashback of
everything that led up to his original
death in the opening of child's play in
his flashback you can actually see the
home video that the pierce family
watched earlier being filmed i thought
that was kind of a cool detail the
flashback also ties together some loose
threads from the beginning of the movie
remember how i pointed out the mother's
medication bottles letting us know that
she isn't well in the home movie scene
barb mentions that this started around
the time that their dad passed away a
couple weeks before nico was born mom
was never the same after that we're led
to believe that one or both of these
events affected sarah's mental health
but the flashback shows us that it was
actually her being kidnapped by charles
lee ray he brings her sunflowers while
she's in captivity and this explains why
she's seen painting a sunflower in the
opening and why her attic is filled with
artwork of these sunflowers it's
basically some kind of coping mechanism
for the horrors that charles subjected
her to nika is just the next target in
sarah's family tree but when the police
arrive chucky goes into barbie mode and
she ends up getting blamed for all the
murders they could have ended the movie
right there and i would have been
satisfied but what we get instead is an
additional six minutes of fan service
for enthusiasts of the chucky continuity
and honestly i'm here for it and it's
totally packed with interesting details
including the previously unknown fate of
beloved legacy and characters
after the trial this police officer
takes the chucky doll along in his squad
car and what would follow is almost an
exact recreation of the opening of bride
of chucky where he makes a phone call
where he mentions don't forget my money
and investigates the evidence bag right
before getting his throat slit from
behind by tiffany's nail file yes she
uses the same one from bride then we see
her shipping chucky to a new destination
which makes a lot more sense than chucky
shipping himself in three and five and
he arrives at alice's new home and tells
her that he wants to play and now
it's time to play
hide and seek hide the soul hide the
soul is the same name of the game that
he uses when he's trying to perform the
dembele chant on tyler in the third
movie could we just play hide and seek
what do you call this game anyway hide
the soul we are led to believe that he's
successful making this his first
successful transfer from the doll body
into a human body again they could have
ended the movie there and i probably
would have been satisfied but we would
have missed out on the post-credits
scene for the first time in over 14
years were reintroduced to andy barkley
who receives a package before his
birthday from the hottest delivery
person that i've ever seen we hear him
on the phone with his mom when he says
this yeah i'm definitely coming for my
birthday tomorrow back in the original
movie chucky was his birthday present
from his mom to him which means chucky
is attacking him one day shy of the
anniversary of their first meeting he
also asks how's mike doing he's
presumably talking about mike norris the
police officer that helped save him and
his mom all of those years ago it's nice
to see that they kept in touch there are
a lot of interesting items in andy's
apartment we see a picture of him and
his mom from when he was six a picture
of kyle from child's play too which is
actually a clue that they're still in
contact as we would see in the next
movie you can also see his diploma from
kent military academy which tells us
that despite getting arrested at the end
of child's play 3 he was still able to
finish school and graduate which also
kind of leads into the next movie cult
of chucky where we see his familiarity
with guns from the academy has stuck
with him over the years but if you want
to hear me talk about cult of chucky
then you'll have to join me in the next
episode of things you missed when that
video comes out you'll find it there on
the left but in the meantime make sure
you subscribe to cz's world for new
horrors every week ring the death bell
and select all notifications and i will
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive
[Music]